[Applause]
here's a challenge for you
after you finish watching this video go
to your kitchen and open the fridge then
try to find something that has been
produced outside of your country and if
you're watching this video from a
European country try to find some
product produced outside of the European
Union mallet she probably can't even
find one
[Music]
maybe this doesn't surprise you well if
you think about it a little more
consider that your mobile phone has been
manufactured in more than 20 different
countries the trousers you're wearing
right now are probably manufactured in
the country like China or Bangladesh and
maybe the company you work for is also
foreign I mean there's no surprises
there I say we all live in a globalized
economy nonetheless food is the
exception to the rule
agriculture is an industry that is
completely protected from foreign
competition now make no mistake here
this has nothing to do with Donald Trump
in fact if you think he's the creator of
trade was well you're actually
absolutely wrong actually the primary
sector exists in a never ending cold war
that's why from time to time we see
headlines like this one
trade war rips through farm world
soybean hog prices fall oh maybe this
one cuts import tariffs in a bid to end
banana Wars but there are more than
tariffs here in fact tariffs are just
one of the many tools used to attack
foreign markets and they're not even the
deadliest here's an example America
spends more than twenty billion dollars
a year in subsidies for their farmers
sound like a lot to you well not
compared to the whopping seventy two
billion dollars that the EU spends in
subsidies every single year and now you
might be wondering but well what do the
subsidies have to do with trade wars and
the answer to that is well a lot
[Music]
for example this milk break you see on
the screen here is worth an average of
60 Euro cents in a Spanish supermarket
from those 60 cents the Spanish farmer
would get 30 cents but his actual
revenue is going to be 44 cents and why
is this well that's because the European
Union will give him a subsidy of 14
cents per liter
thanks to this grant the farmer can sell
cheap and still make money and this is
why Europe doesn't need to buy African
sugar despite it being cheaper or even
more surprisingly why American or
European producers can smash the
competition from African markets despite
their having higher wages but hold on a
minute here because things are about to
change and this time the free market
champion is not America it's not Japan
or even Australia dear viewer despite
what you might expect if there is
somebody willing to start an
agricultural liberalisation it's
actually the European Union
[Music]
Emmanuel macron breaks French taboo on
farm subsidies a French president
questioning these subsidies on farming
is like a hipster closing his Instagram
accounts it's something that's never
been done before
fears the so-called Common Agricultural
Policy also known as the C ap has been
one of the pillars of the European Union
and France is by far its biggest
supporter but like I said things they're
about to change so now the question
becomes is Europe really ready to
liberalize its agricultural sector are
we about to see the ends of the food
trade Wars and most importantly of all
here is this good or bad news well in
this video we are going to answer all of
these questions but before we do let's
take a look back at the history
[Music]
what is CA P used for let's imagine that
we have a wheat farm in Essex in the UK
we harvest the crop and go to sell it to
the market
[Music]
last time we did we received 175 pounds
per ton so it makes sense to expect to
sell it for a similar price this time
around right well actually no I mean
maybe this time the market price for
wheat is actually just a hundred and
fifty pounds per ton this is a reality
that every farmer faces every year by
contrast the price of an iPhone it
doesn't really change much over time so
if we sell iPhones we can make good
predictions about our income but wheat
corn oil or any other commodity can
change their market price from one day
to the next
[Music]
and I might be wondering well why why
does this happen was the difference
between wheat and an iPhone well the
difference is that commodities they're
the same everywhere maybe you ate some
bread today could you tell me where the
wheat it was made from was produced well
probably not the same goes with the oil
used to produce gasoline that you put in
your car you don't know if it's Saudi or
Canadian and you don't really care you
just want it to be as absolutely cheap
as possible nonetheless there are just a
few dinosaur juice producers meanwhile
there are many producers of wheat corn
and potatoes so if one big producer had
a good harvest that's going to affect
that market price for everybody and then
of course you've got to add to this the
weather too little rain too much rain or
an unusually cold Windsor can be enough
to kill off all of your revenue
nonetheless
we need agriculture because
unfortunately you cannot eat oil or
iPhones
so how can we keep eating while farmers
don't starve
now this might sound like a stupid
question but believe me it's actually
one of the hardest problems in economics
and well this is where that Common
Agricultural Policy that we mentioned
comes into play this is how the European
Union protects their farmers
[Music]
let me talk about the c.a.p we're
talking about the cornerstone of the
European Union it was a thing
even before the Schengen area or the
euro zone were even born actually do you
know who the father of the c.a.p was
well yeah it was that French president
Charles de Gaulle
[Music]
Nishan has no friends only interests
charles degaulle now if you've been
subscribed to visual politic for a while
you already know that charles de gaulle
was not exactly a big fan of the free
markets well actually he wasn't really a
big fan of anyone except himself
really this is why when France became a
member of the European single market
what would later become the European
Union he added a condition he basically
said all right we're gonna sign up but
you've got to promise us that nobody's
going to become our competition for
farmers all right and basically that's
how the ca PU is born a policy that is
so interventionalist it makes Bernie
Sanders look like Warren Buffett
basically in order to compensate for
potential losses when market prices go
down the European Union gives them
direct cash for example if you have a
barn with cows in Spain Brussels will
still give you cash straight away for
each and every cow that you own and if
you want to buy a milking machine that
is going to make you more productive
well Brussels is gonna help you with
that too this way Europe is not only
guaranteeing your income but it's also
helping to protect you from American or
African producers and as you might have
already imagined all of this aid costs a
its load of money
[Music]
so if you want to get a better idea
during the 1990s the c.a.p comprised 80%
of the whole European budget and even
now when Europe is bigger and it's got
more stuff to do
the c.a.p still makes up 40% of all EU
spending and surprise surprise I guess
which country receives most of the age
of course it's France but hold on just a
moment because things they do not stop
right here beyond direct aid Europe also
has other tactics to avoid price
fluctuations as well as quotas and
tariffs
[Music]
for example in order to avoid a price
drop in milk Europe used to put a
production limit on each country that
means that you couldn't produce more
than a certain number of litres and of
course he was benefiting the most from
these production quotas well of course
it was the country of Brussels and per
guess as you can imagine this milk rotor
created all kinds of problems among the
other members and this is why despite
French pressure Europe how to put an end
to all of this
[Music]
and of European milk quotas a new era
for the French dairy sector and of
course we also have the tariffs tariffs
they're like sniper bullets designed to
stop very specific products from getting
into European markets for example
imagine that you are an Argentinean
coffee producer if you want to sell your
raw coffee meaning you take it from the
plant and sell it Europe they got no
problem zero tariffs for you and why is
that well it's because no European
country grows coffee but if you want to
sell this coffee and it's already
toasted and processed form well good
luck to you you're gonna have to pay a
tariff of 7.5% and why is that well
because Europe as factories that process
and toast coffee and they just don't
really like competition
[Applause]
[Music]
but I know what you're thinking right
now oh that evil European Union they're
punishing the third world those Brussels
bureaucrats they just want to destroy
free trade well I've actually got bad
news for you because the reality is that
every country on the planet does the
exact same thing in fact when it comes
to tariffs Europe is actually one of the
most open regions
for example if the same farmer wants to
sell his coffee in Japan he's going to
have to pay a 20 percent tariff if he
wants to sell bananas then he has to pay
between 40 and 50 percent depending on
the season and what about America the
lands of the free
well it's actually kind of the same
there
almost no country is willing to leave
its farmers alone in order to compete
with fair competition nonetheless all of
this can change and why well let's have
a look at that times for protectionism
every year Europe spends over seventy
two billion dollars subsidizing its own
farmers but as you can imagine not all
the country members pay the same amounts
just have a look at this chart here you
can see the main contributors that is
the countries that pay more than what
they get and surprise surprise here who
is the third biggest c.a.p net
contributor well of course that's the
United Kingdom the country that will no
longer be a member of the club as you
can imagine this leaves a hole of more
than 12 billion euros this is why many
are suggesting that other countries have
to start paying more to keep the
spending where it used to be
[Music]
European Commission
urges EU countries to pay more into
budget nonetheless who really wants to
pay more it's a time when Euroskeptic
parties are stronger than ever and no
politician can really come back to his
own country and say hey guess what guys
without your wallet because we got to
pay more for being in the EU it's not
going to go down well so if you do the
math you realize that there's only
really one option left
Buster's plans to cut its payments to
Europe's biggest farms basically Europe
had to reduce the direct aid given to
the farmers and they have started with
the wealthiest ones since they're the
ones who needed them the least but the
biggest surprise came with Emmanuel
macron speech everybody in Brussels
might expect France to come out as the
biggest old-school c.a.p supporter right
but macron well he's got other
priorities and this means a green light
to cut aid in the future meanwhile trade
deals being struck in fashion
[Applause]
you and Mexico agreed to new free trade
pact yes yes yes i'ma not only talking
about Mexico here I mean look at this
news the European Union rushed to
promote its preliminary free trade
agreement with Japan by stressing the
benefits for EU farmers yes if you are
slowly the European Union is reducing
subsidies reducing tariffs and getting
rid of production quotas and I know what
you're probably thinking right now
you're thinking come on Simon are you
really telling us that brexit is the
only reason for this change
well no I'm certainly not in fact there
are two other important reasons on the
one hand European agriculture is already
more productive than elsewhere in this
video we've told you about the
Netherlands being one of the biggest
agricultural powerhouses in fact they
have what we call the food Silicon
Valley in fact camera bet she is a
Ribera del Duero wine can be found
almost everywhere and they all come from
Europe in other words Europe doesn't
need to protect its own market anymore
but instead sign lots of trade deals and
I know what you might be thinking right
now will farmers be happy when they stop
getting all of these subsidies from
Brussels well the reality is no but the
question really is this is actually
matter look peasants unions they used to
have a big political grip during the 60s
when de Gaulle was the French president
Francois death of people working in the
primary sector now there aren't even
three percent of the population working
there
this means way less political sway and
way less votes but not only that who do
you think these European farmers vote
for
[Music]
Frances disillusion farmers turn tulip
em exactly basically the biggest place
for Euroskeptic parties to get their
votes are rural areas where farmers live
so if you're a European politician and
you want to make your voters happy yet
really kinda do want to pay more
attention to their urban Europeana
status instead of the rural Euroskeptic
ones and come on now because the average
City guy they don't know what the CA P
even is
[Music]
then this leads us to our question for
you does the CA P have any future
whatsoever in Europe will we see greater
liberalisation of agriculture in Europe
as well as the rest of the world well
please leave your answer in the comments
section below also please do visit our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine don't forget to check
out our patreon page where you can
support our channel and gain access to
some exclusive content and also as
always give us a thumbs up and subscribe
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]